in the good old times people learned how
to read and to write that's no longer
sufficient in the high-tech 21st century
we also need to know how to deal with
risk and uncertainty and that is what I
mean with risk savvy here is a simple
example you hear on the weather report
that there is a 30% chance of rain
tomorrow
30% chains of what now I live in Berlin
and most Berliners believe that it means
that it will rain in 30% of the time
that is 7 to 8 hours
other think it will rain in 30% of the
region most New Yorkers believe that's
all nonsense it means it will rain on
30% of the days for which this
prediction has been made that is most
likely not at all many psychologists
think that people can't learn how to
deal with risk but in this case it's the
experts the meteorologists who have not
learned how to communicate risk in an
understandable way that is to say to
what class the 30 percent refers time or
region or days and if you have some
imagination you can think about other
classes for instance one women in New
York said I know what 30 percent means
three meteorologists think it rains and
seven not now getting soaked is a minor
risk but are we risk savvy when it comes
to more important things
for instance 20 year-olds drive with the
cell phone glued to their ears not
realizing that they decrease their
reaction time to that of a 70 year old
or many Americans about 20 percent
believe that they are in the top 1%
income group
and as many believe there will be soon
be there or take health so about an
estimated 1 million children get every
year
unnecessary computed tomography CT scans
unnecessary because they're not really
clinically indicated which is not just a
waste of time but also a danger to the
kids because a CT scan can have the
radiation of a hundred chest x-rays and
may lead in a small number of these kids
later to cancer we deal every day with
risk but we haven't learned how to
understand them and the problem is not
simple in the human mind but also in
experts who either don't know what the
risks are or don't know how to
communicate them or in other areas like
if it's about finance or health have
interests other than yours so the key
message is this everyone can learn to
deal with risk in that case everyone can
learn to ask the question probability of
what and second if you believe that
you're safe by your delegating the
responsibilities of your wealth and
health to experts then you may be
disappointed because many experts do not
know how to communicate probabilities or
try to protect themselves against you as
in health care as a potential plaintiff
so you have to think yourself and that's
the key message
you